no where is Britain's patchy record a
marine protection brought into sharper
focus than on the Goodwin Sands we have
the most important one is the sand eel
which is the basis of the whole
ecosystem the conservationists the shoal
six miles off the Kent coast is a
special place where seals haul out and
rare species still thrive in the
shallows but its protected status won't
stop the Port of Dover dredging 3
million tons of sand from the area to
use as construction material it's a
complete mockery I mean how can you
conserve something if you can and then
allow people to take away 3 million tons
of it it just doesn't make sense it's
totally illogical and the government's
got to be really robust and stand-ups
and say these conservation zones are for
conservation 3,000 miles away in New
York Britain called on world leaders
gathering for the United Nations General
Assembly to protect 30% of the world's
oceans by 2030 currently it's not even
4% we are one of the great marathon
countries of the world our shipping
channel of the English Channel is one of
the busiest in the world that doesn't
mean that we have to damage the
environment we can do marine
conservation and have a sustainable
economy so having that partnership
they're showing again by leadership it's
something that we can work with other
countries to make sure we achieve
together Sky News closed he followed
Louis Pugh's records swim from Land's
End to Dover as part of the ocean rescue
campaign highlighting poor marine
protection he welcomed the announcement
as a bold start
I saw a few dolphins I saw a few birds
I saw one turtle and not much else our
oceans have been so badly over fished
and then when I went onto the beaches
you know all the way along the beaches
where I was walking there was plastic
pollution it's almost like we have
hoovered up the fish and thrown into
plastic and so today's announcement is
very very exciting if Britain is to lead
the world on marine protection it needs
to start here now sources tell me that
the Environment Secretary is sympathetic
to the case for Goodwin Sands and in the
longer term that could be much stronger
safeguards for all our conservation
zones
the seas have long been seen as a
resource to plunder often at the cost of
the environment proper marine protection
would ensure the world's oceans have a
more sustainable future Thomas More Sky
News and the Goodwin Sands